so to the best of my ability given what
my job is I've been avoiding a lot of
death stranding news and trailers it's
kind of like because I want to be able
to satisfy my curiosity once I have that
game in front of me but I know like the
the biggest talking point is like none
of this has made any sense and if this
makes any sense and Peter you actually
got to talk to Kojima last week yeah and
it sounds like it actually does make
sense and one of the things that caught
my eye in your interview was the concept
of a moiety can you explain that a
little bit actually
cuz I'm still kind of confused the best
I can apparently there's not really like
a strong English equivalent but the
closest would be like you know having
empathy or compassion but completely and
that doesn't necessarily mean just like
doing something nice for somebody it
means like really trying to understand
where they're coming from what it is
they do or do not feel or have or do not
have and you know I think a lot of the
stuff Kojima talks about what des
training has to do with connection and
we as gamers know that that means that
means connecting between each other but
the stuff we've seen has been pretty
sort of surface level right like we've
an item for someone or like leave a note
which is stuff we've all seen before but
that's always existed in games at least
to my recollection as sort of like an
aspect of the experience of Kojima was
telling me is that this concept of Omaha
D is sort of his his focus for this
entire aspect of the game and he
described it as like you know when you
go to a restaurant in Japan they're not
they're just there to serve you food and
make you happy cuz they're eating in
tips like in America you know they
really do go out of their way and it's
true and a lot of my experience is to
make you feel like hey you're at home
you don't have to worry about anything
whatever you need will take care of you
and it just it's it's like they're
putting themselves in your shoes when
they're serving you and they really want
to understand what it is they can do to
make you happy and I don't know that the
stuff we've seen is going to do that for
me like if I find that water bottle that
you left I don't I don't know that I'm
gonna think oh my god this this person
like knows me and you know whatever but
whatever thing but the fact that that
Kojima is developing the game to try to
convey that specifically to me is very
interesting and it does help explain a
little bit of why
these things it seems so minor might all
add up to something bigger yeah I think
in reading that interview I got a better
understanding of I talked to you guys
about this earlier like I got a better
understanding of where Kadima was coming
from when he said I don't really know
what the game is about because I think I
feel like and I'm gonna sound like an
academia apologist or like which is not
why want to sound like but I think the
thing that he's coming from is like I
don't I what I've put in here is a
feeling it's a it's an ethos it's a it's
a way of life kind of almost like this
is an experience that I have had like
how do you tangibly take those kind of
ideas and themes and feelings and put
them into a way that people can
understand it's gotta be difficult right
yeah and he's the kind of person who
traditionally avoids trying to reduce
his games or experiences to things that
the broader industry and the broader you
know fan base of games would want like
you know genre tags he kind of shied
away from that for better or worse for
some from some people's perspective it's
you know arrogance he doesn't want to
say you know call a spade a spade and
say it's an action game open-world
exploration game but for others it's
like he's trying for like for me I I
take as I think she's trying to think
about it from a different angle that's a
little more stirring a little more
interesting I mean all he says is that
yeah I mean he did name this like you
know social strand system and strand
action game but according to him he only
came up with those things because people
just kept asking him what is this and so
for lack of a better a reason that's why
he came up with the name for it the
whole like what is this conversation
annoyed me though because it was just
like do we have to always know like I
think a lot of people treat like trailer
announcements as like another PR
opportunity or like we have to get all
the information out of this that we can
and I think to some extent like we do
that in our jobs because that's what
people who play games are interested in
like what can we glean from this
information as if it's a puzzle we put
together but with this it's like it's it
seems to me especially from the
interview that you did with Kojima
but it's about evoking a feeling and
that's not something you get from
marketing and like I don't know I it's
it's one of those things like I don't
need to know everything about what it is
before I play it yeah and he did lay out
a bunch of stuff at TGS right to satisfy
the sort of curiosity of people who are
like look I'm not looking at this as a
thought experiment I'm looking at this
as a video game I might purchase and so
yeah he kind of explained like all right
here we go we're gonna win through
almost an hour of gameplay like I mean
walking around the environment you're
going to be leading things that other
players might use to traverse set
environment you're going to be trying to
connect different parts of America like
all that stuff kind of makes sense on
paper but you know he said you know he's
noticing a lot of Western media sort of
characterized this as oh it's just a
walking simulator yeah which I think
under sells some of it you know okay
he's not like a hundred percent from top
to bottom the most thoughtful person in
the world as we see him yeah right like
he has a lot of like tongue-in-cheek
kind of like jokey things like we were
joking about names like hot cold mener
li ER or mama or whatever you know like
he's not everything is this huge deep
thoughtful thing but I think P you can
pee but oh to be fair and that actually
I cut that from the interview because it
didn't really like it wasn't relevant
but I thanked him for putting that in a
game because there are no games that
make you go to the bathroom and it's
ridiculous
I bailed you we didn't hear back on that
I digress so you know yes people are
focusing on the mechanics of the game
that they show him or that they showed
us but I think it's also worth giving
him some credit some benefit of the
doubt that like there's there's more to
this than just the things you're doing
there's the reason you're doing it and
frankly he said a lot of this is to
combat the sort of you know negative
like false form of communication that
exists online between people where it's
not anyone you're not actually
communicating with each other you're
just kind of like saying things at one
another from usually from an anonymous
position or whatever and it can be
positive or negative he's trying to
create it's quite according to him like
you know a a game that teaches you the
power of positivity and caring for
others like through this if you will
walking simulator type and he
specifically mentions like
uses the little thing where you know
someone at war is sending a letter to a
loved one at home but there's that delay
where the actual layer has to be given
to the military who will then take care
of sending it so it's often like months
before the other person receives it and
the person who reads Allah then has to
put themselves in the shoes of the
person that sent it their loved one
I think about what were they
experiencing at the time what were they
the meaning they were trying to glean
from it and that's a really interesting
way to come at this concept of you know
leaving messages or doing things that
impact the world that other other people
can experience themselves and you know
we've had we've had it we've seen it
done in like from soft games and stuff
and various other games the way you
leave a message but it's always like
either vague or like very direct like
door up ahead or boss up ahead or
something like that there's this is a
version of it which like let me truly
think about why this person left the
letterhead but it didn't reach the other
side but what does that mean like is it
is it up to me to take that as a I tried
my best and this is the best like I do
or is this the case of I'm here trying
to trick people into drowning in this
right and so he was saying I was like
okay you had you talked this big game
about everyone like working together
like in harmony but what's to stop
people from trolling each other like he
actually described a scenario where like
maybe there's a ladder that takes you
out like you know over a cliff maybe you
fall off that cliff because letters
don't go all the way yeah he really just
repeated himself he's like I don't think
there would be intentional evil between
players which that seems a little naive
to me yeah I hate to say I like and you
know to his admission he doesn't get to
play many games these days
I don't know that he really understands
how people will act when they have that
connection when they they can do stuff
like that with impunity right nothing's
gonna happen to them like yeah he has a
system for rewarding people that do good
things right there's like a like system
but there's been no like punishment type
system that's been described and I I do
worry a little bit that that might
derail some of what he's going for and
ultimately some of what death stranding
might be at its core
yeah it's like you have to wonder if
what the game is and like I said I've
been avoiding because I think it's
something that I just want to experience
like it seems like something that's
intended to just be experienced and not
like dissected from trailers I I would
hope that something about it encourages
earnestness like earnest T so like I
next he goes to Hollywood Wow I I would
hope that people come into it with a
honest lay open on good perspective yeah
on good faith like inert like engage
with that in good faith because yeah I
mean obviously there are people who are
not but I think some games make that
easier for people to do because there is
no way to put it over I mean technically
like you could leave a rope in this game
that takes someone down a cliff
and like they can't get maybe they can't
get back up because they have to drop
down to the next ledge because maybe
they live in a world where everyone's is
so nice but then they meet that one
person who's like oh you're trapped and
he described that you can get trapped
like in something like that and so you
have to literally take your own life
you jump off that cliff and in that
moment like his point is like in that
moment I want people to consider that
action the wasn't evil like yeah he did
it by accident yeah like maybe they did
it by accident maybe that person didn't
have the rope to make it all the way and
suffered a similar fate but also like I
think he kind of like I don't know if is
its if it's the translation or maybe I'm
reading into into it differently but it
seemed like he wanted to people to think
like is this something that I would do
like would I do this now like if you're
on the receiving end of something that's
like that a troll or a misfortunate
event like that he wants you to think
man I'd never do this to anyone because
it feels rough and that's at least an
interesting way to approach something
that's common in games now like leaving
messages reinforcing that though I think
it's going to have to come from what the
story is trying to do yeah that's kind
of I was getting at it so when it comes
to not understanding what des training
is I'm cool saying that about the story
and and reveling in that because I think
that's half the fun is discovering where
weird twists yes what strange characters
of course but you know what what the
messaging is could you
always has some sort of commentary
there's been a couple other interviews
where he gets into that a little bit but
you know if not in the system's
themselves maybe the story will be the
thing that really gets people into the
mindset that we're talking about where
it's it's meant to be sympathetic it's
meant to be empathetic that's sort of
fries getting at like maybe there's a
way to put people in the right headspace
to get into that like to get into the
Amoy aadhi yeah I feeling I think part
of it is like Norman Reedus also like
complains about things like like vocally
during the game like so he's like God is
so difficult or so arduous like out loud
yeah so maybe that might even like put
you in a state of where you feel some
sympathy for what he's going nobody
wants to disappoint Norman Reedus
yeah I don't assume okay
yeah I don't get either but I guess like
that doesn't make sense like if he's
complaining constantly and then you're
playing as him and then you find that
water bottle that I left you maybe you
will be inclined to be like dancing good
war ball yeah thanks I feel like it's
there's a little bit of like willful
ignorance which is happening on the
internet right now which I'm not here to
take a stance on but it seems like the
thing to do is be like oh I don't get
this game at all this is so wacky look
at Kojima being so weird and again I'm
not a canoe man one man cuz you're my
defense force but like I like it I'd
like to see him like very very obviously
dance around of you know like things
like genre tropes and things like Jean
relabeled
to create something that's sounds
ridiculous but at least makes you think
about it a little deeper he could have
said it's an open-world walking
simulator where you carry luggage or
open-world puzzle game or survival game
but like at the end of the day like you
just that means you just in your mind
it's just the mystique is gone like do
you do you still have that kind of like
desire to figure it out when someone's
gone it's an open world survival game
you don't versus what is being around me
yeah exactly
or even like when you have an
expectation for what a survival game or
open world survival survival game is
then it doesn't do that thing yeah then
you're put in a position to be
disappointed if you have that
expectation yeah so why create that
expectation agreed yeah I feel like he
just people need to relax a bit
let the man and his team of various
people who have clearly put a lot of
time effort and thought into it do their
thing instead of just being so ready to
snap a day and tear it down and not give
him the benefit that that will give them
their benefit I don't want to act like
it's just him doing on his own yeah sure
and honestly what you're saying should
be true for most game developers and
Studios that haven't burned their
audience in the past and to that point I
think like Kojima has a pretty strong
track record of delivering games that
either meet or surpass expectations I
mean he didn't get to where he is and
his team didn't get to where they are by
doing things worthy of ridicule like
there are things that are in there that
are definitely open to debate and in
some cases probably ridiculed but at the
same time like there's so much
interesting stuff in his in his history
that it yeah it just seems worth giving
him a little bit of our trust yeah but
also like just being okay with not
understanding things like not everything
needs to be explained well that's part
of the reason I love control yeah like
you know not every piece of you know
whatever you want to call it art media
whatever not everything needs to be like
clean-cut and perfectly tied up with a
bow like it's okay for it to be
confusing hmm
and I I just get frustrated with the
like it's positioned to such a negative
point like we don't know anything about
just ranting yet and it's like well we
don't know if it's good or bad yeah we
just don't know we have it we don't know
what the experience is to be a person
playing that's training that's all like
that's the question we need to answer
but why answer like what is it I just
really love that there's this game
coming out that is just so singular
of a vision that a group of people that
had have had that there's others that
don't understand it and that's like I
think I feel like this is something to
be liked
in high regard and praised that someone
has announced the game was showing off a
game that everyone isn't immediately
like I know exactly what that is right
it's not I know that is a third-person
cover shooter and I feel like the we're
kind of by getting caught up and hung up
on like a telepathy I don't understand
this at all it kind of ruins the magic
of games a bit like why do you need to
understand it like Addison
like to remember when you looked at a
game and was like I don't get this I'm
so excited to unpack it and figure it
out it's exactly what you said about
control right like I feel like remedy
were masterful in how much they reveal
their like and perhaps is it even more
of an achievement for them because the
building blocks of that game are very
familiar it looks like a shooting game
but then the more you play the more you
realized I don't understand this at all
but I'm like desperate to and I'm like
picking it apart and figuring out and
then you come away with like an
experience and you come away like
changed by it or at least you have it an
impression of it on your your life your
gaming career whatever it may be your
experience at least the time you played
with it is like I tried to figure this
thing out
I'm so glad that they're making a game
where it's like we're not gonna explain
this to you you're gonna play the game
and you'll experience it anyway you like
it or you won't
but yeah I'm kind of reveling in the
fact that it feels so good to be excited
about a game that I know is gonna catch
me off-guard if you go I'm saying like
I'm playing stuff like Borderlands right
now and I'm enjoying it but it's still
like it's Borderlands I know exactly
what I'm getting at is that game is
marketing itself
yeah there's merit in that too like it's
not that like exact unexplained is
better than like something straight
forward it's different it can't be held
at the same stage yeah I mean like Fire
Emblem is a great example of that like
it's it's - it's very familiar pieces
but it's still a really good game and
I'm enjoying it but at the same time I'm
playing Fire Emblem and I'm like I get
this I like what I'm playing but I get
it gears I know what this is that's
trending I'm like I know when I picked
that up it's gonna be something that I
don't really understand for a really
long time and I'm not 100% sure whether
I like it or not I'm excited about that
I love when I get a feel
out of a piece of media like there are
things that you know I can't even
explain like what it's really about or
even if I can explain what it's about
like I think a lot of poetry is like
that honestly like maybe that's like a
stuffy answer but like I think something
that imparts a feeling on to you is
really powerful and you don't have to
understand all the parts so I'm looking
forward to like maybe never
understanding what does training like is
really about but getting my own
experience out of it and I think the
concept of omoi tea that you talked
about with him has really sold me on it
like that is such a cool powerful thing
to me that like yes it's not a Japanese
only concept but like we don't have an
English word for it and so to hear or to
read about him explaining that and like
what that means that's not a thing that
we actively think about right in our day
to day life and I'm I'm really excited
to get something out of that even if
it's not understanding like a real-life
analogy that I went through I used to do
hiking a lot you know in the Appalachian
Trail sometimes you have to go through
towns and so you would exit the woods
and you'd get like a little like you
know but maybe like half a mile you'd
have to walk through a town so people
would leave coolers like locals would be
of coolers with sodas and water for the
hikers and stuff and he was describing
this like cabin amount fuji that sort of
serves the same purpose as like your
safe house you know industry and i was
like having experienced something like
that in the real world like i
immediately thought wow this is really
awesome
I wonder who are the people that did
this that's so kind of that like this
whole narrative about who they are why
they did it like maybe where that came
from for them like that all went through
my mind if if he can pull that off in
game worm awesome I am a little
skeptical still but I have hope and I
want it to have its the idea of paying
forward isn't that like yeah what do you
do that of course with a balance of
things such as staring at Norman Reedus
dude yeah you know it's y'see right I
think more in Grenada not his actual
pain but you can stare at his crotch
when he's like resting in his safe
because you know you're actually
controlling the soul that controls what
he does see this is this is when death
starts - yeah that ahjumma described it
as that we showed your game yeah well I
am totally in the dark on that yeah
we're all going Norman Reedus they're
like he's in the room but the
justification is that you're a soul yeah
there is such a big market for that if
you want but that's just it I think is
that there's a there's a lot of things
that death stranding can be and that it
is so like maybe you sure the walking
simulator part doesn't do it for you
right but you can still expect a ton of
melodrama right
probably some twists probably some
messaging about you know real life
beyond the internet that we're
describing with Illinois yachty like
mm-hmm
it was gonna be a lot to this game that
people will find interesting yeah no
idea it's gonna be good I'm just curious
to find out mm-hmm well yeah I am more
curious after this conversation yeah I
was already like so in the dark that I
was at the Norman Reedus thing it was
definitely you know contributed to it
sure sure um yeah like it remains to be
seen obviously but it's coming out very
soon relatively hmm like I know the
curse snuck up on me yeah let us know
what you think about the game Kali is no
I'm the soul in the room more like a
drama raining Peters I have some of that
all right that's how he shouldn't sure
we have that